la vuelta de Benjamin de tanyahu al
gobierno de Israel supone un viraje a la
extrema derecha sin precedentes de los
120 escaños que tiene el acné set el
parlamento israelí netanyahu se llevó 64
de ellos su partido el de Cut obtuvo 32
escaños sus aliados Ultra ortodoxos 18 y
los ultranacionalistas del sionismo
religioso 14 los líderes de este último
se oponen a la creación de un estado
palestino quieren la anexión de la
cisjordania ocupada y en el pasado eran
antiderechos lgbtiq más uno de ellos y
tomar bengevir fue condenado en 2007 por
incitación racista contra los árabes y
apoyo al terrorismo a pesar de esto Bibi
como se le conoce a netanyahu dijo que
haría un gobierno para todos
el público de los votantes ha confiado
inequívocamente en mí y en mi partido
likuth así como en los partidos que se
asocian a nosotros
pero quiero decir Tengo la intención de
ser el Primer Ministro de todos de los
que me eligieron y de los que no no es
solo una forma de decirlo refleja lo que
creo en lo profundo de mi alma y lo que
guía mis acciones
pero el temor por su gestión aumenta
entre los opositores ya que la derecha
Espera a probar reformas judiciales que
son vistas como desfavorables
podría también asumir el control total
sobre el nombramiento de los jueces del
tribunal supremo desde el lado palestino
el nuevo gobierno es mal percibido en su
periodo de 12 años como Primer Ministro
aumentaron los asentamientos israelíes
en territorios ocupados tras la llegada
de vivienda Yahoo de nuevo al poder
varios países occidentales entre ellos
Estados Unidos pidieron tolerancia y
respeto a los grupos minoritarios